(upbeat music)
- Hello, everyone and
welcome to the Sunglow
here Bicknell, Utah.
My name is Bessie Stewart, and today
we're going to make our famous pickle pie.
Pickle pie a dessert; it's
not the sweetest pie we have,
but it is the most original.
It took a lot of imagination I
think to invent a dessert pie
with a pickle in it.
The original owner found
the recipe in a magazine.
She didn't like the recipe at
all so she changed it around,
and now the pickle pie is the very best.
Just far as I know we are the only place
that makes the pickle pie.
(upbeat music)
In pickle pie you will
find sugar, butter, milk,
eggs, lemon extract, corn
starch, cinnamon, nutmeg,
and, of course, the pickles.
So we've got this all mixed
in really nice and smooth,
so now we're gonna pour it
into our unbaked pie shell
to put in the oven.
Scrape the edges so
you get all the flavor.
This one right here is one
that we baked this morning.
Wow, pickle pie.
This is delicious.
Little tiny bit of cream on it.
Just gives it that little
bit of sweet and sour
that you need to set off the taste buds.
So, mmm.
The customers like the
pickle pie, but I think
the biggest selling point is curiosity.
- This looks like a delicious pie.
- It tastes very similar to a pumpkin pie.
- It's got a hint of pickle to it.
- But, it's not like
overpowering or anything.
- Good flavor, sweet.
- A little sweet.
- It's, like, super sweet.
- It's not really sweet.
- I think it's gonna sell.
- Bicknell is a very small little town.
We are about three hours
from Salt Lake City.
And you don't have to
live in a great big city
to have good food.
You have to have pride and an imagination.
It's more than just a pie.
It's your work of art.
It's something that you have done.
And it looks pretty and it tastes good,
and you can be proud of it.
(upbeat music)